Ron Jaworski former Eagles quarterback
now works for NFL Network NFL Films his
film session former ESPN NFL analyst and
jaws works joining us now hey Joss how
are you today Dan I am doing fantastic
it's Dallas Week in Philadelphia so
everyone's antenna is up in a huge game
in Philly so uh but first of all a Merry
Christmas Happy Holidays to you and your
your folks well thank you you too jaws
is that your normal voice when you wake
up in the morning yes my wife says turn
it off I said that is this Carson when
she's Superbowl no but it's a big game
for him and clearly Dan he has played
very well the last couple weeks he had a
stretcher games where he was not playing
well and that was a kind of getting the
attention of everyone here in
Philadelphia is this the kind of guy
that's going to lead us to a Super Bowl
but he has performed remarkably well the
last couple weeks and despite the
tremendous turnover to wide receiving
corps his game has picked up but I think
Doug Peterson has really helped them I
think they've simplified the game plan
and they were forced to because of
practice squad players now being asked
to make plays in big games and they have
done that by the way but I think the
simplification of the game plan and
using Carson's Carson Wentz under center
a little bit more has helped him but you
have Dallas and I know it feels like the
media turned this into it's a dak
Prescott led team when in reality it's
probably still in Ezekiel Elliott led
offense here what's the game plan for
Dallas against Philadelphia you know I
go back to the heyday of the Dallas
Cowboys and their great success with
Troy Aikman Michael Irvin and Emmitt
Smith and what great teams as the
Cowboys had in that era and everyone
talked about you know lemon Smith Emmitt
Smith Emmitt Smith it's certainly a
fantastic Hall of Fame football player
but just watching how Jimmy Johnson ran
that offense in Dallas what they did is
they scored early they were very
aggressive early in games with the
passing game they liked to play with a
lead and make the other team's offense
one-dimensional in other words playing
from behind
so they they would come out and they
would come out smoking they would try to
score early and make you one-dimensional
and then pound the ball with Emmitt
Smith and I think quite honestly that's
when this Dallas Cowboy team is at its
best when they are throwing early and
then grinding the clock you know with
Ezekiel Elliott so I expect the Cowboys
come out in this game the Eagles
secondary has struggled their pass rush
has not been what it was cranked up to
be when the season started their
linebackers or ball over and pass
coverage so if dak is healthy which is
the big news yesterday you know the
missing practice with the shoulder
injury if he's healthy I think they come
out and throw the ball early really yes
because I thought if you if you run it
and then you set up play-action and then
you allow dak Prescott to take some
shots downfield and then you come back
to your running game you know in the
second half or in the fourth quarter but
I did I think if you if you look at the
strength of this Eagles defense it is
their defensive line they don't give up
many yards rushing you know that's where
they've spent their money so when you
spend your money you believe those are
your best players and they have been
very good against the run so I I think
Dallas will take it take a different
approach to this game and try to throw
the ball early and and you know again a
lot will depend on zekiel Elliott and
you know how he's feeling of course that
Prescott how he's feeling injuries are
absolutely critical at this juncture of
the season but I'm looking at down it
feels like Dallas has a little bit
higher ceiling if they get into the
postseason as opposed to the Eagles I I
think right now I would agree with you I
mean it when the season started you know
I kind of circle this game myself you
know there's there's a part of me that
always says you know Eagles Dallas's is
the one that you know you circle the
wagons on per se and and I did not
expected this to be a gate a big game
but I did not expect this to be 2 7 7 in
teams meeting this late in the season I
thought we were looking at 10 11 win
teams playing for a division title not 7
and 7 but the Eagles have been decimated
by injuries
the Cowboys been decimated by
inconsistent play but I think if you
look at the rosters right now at this
point in the season the Cowboys have the
better roster talking to Ron Jaworski
former Eagles quarterback now an analyst
for the NFL Network his film sessions
which team feels like they're in the
worst shape right now in the NFL in the
NFL yep the Cincinnati Bengals they've
been a train wreck for a long time and
they still are so they've got they've
got a lot of a lot of issues they need
to solve to become a competitive team so
yeah I would say when you look at the
Bengals right now they're in the worst
shape yeah but I look at you know like
the Chargers are you know they're lost
you know they do have talent but they're
not even welcomed in there in Los
Angeles they need a quarterback what
else how the Browns situation feels like
it's a little mad Jaguars is a mess
yeah the Jaguars news yesterday was was
it was stunning to me you know I mean
when Tom Coughlin gets fired boy that
that is a strong strong statement you
know Tom was a wide receivers coaching
in the early 80s here in Philadelphia
and I think he's one of the finest
people I've ever met and and you know
for a guy to get fired for whatever the
reasons are you only only know what I
read that's kind of shocking and you
mentioned the Chargers I guess you would
probably look at the overall situation
it's kind of a mess right now you know
they play 16 road games it's difficult
you got an aging quarterback who's
really you know not the guy for the
future so yeah they have issues as well
and and the Browns continue to amaze
people with their issues but if how did
the media miss out on the Browns because
we always get caught up and we were
rooting for this is that what you think
happened with the Browns where everybody
was all in and thought this team could
go to the Superbowl and Baker Mayfield
was going to be an MVP candidate yeah I
think it all starts with the quarterback
and obviously I'm biased in my feelings
that but you just have to look at the
history of this league and if you've got
the quarterback you know you contend for
the playoffs every single year and and I
think the performance of Baker Mayfield
led us to believe you know he could be
the guy but he clearly has regressed
this year the repetitive accuracy just
has not been there there seems to be a
lack of definition of what they want to
do offensively and when you got a guy
like jump I think it's always
you know and pound it and you know use
Baker and what he does best is moving
the deep ball accuracy those sorts of
things and you know it's a very good
wide receiving core so that is a big
surprise to me this season that the
Cleveland has not performed like I
thought they would if Tom Brady asked
you should he continue to play what
would you tell him yes I think Tom can
still play I think tom has lost a little
bit of a sass ball this year but more
importantly he has no weapons I mean he
has no weapons I watch this offensive
going oh my god it's so pedestrian the
wide receiver spotted the tight end spot
it's just you know tom has to be perfect
on literally every throw yeah but I
wonder if the Patriots don't have
Edelman well what kind of chances do you
give them if did you know we always look
at the Patriots and you say Super Bowl
or bust it feels like are they a
Superbowl caliber team obviously I'm not
giving you a quick reaction so I'm a
little bit torn
I've watched you sleep now that you are
getting a little bit healthier than the
offensive line and that will help but
offensively they have been somewhat of a
train wreck this year they just have not
been able to find something to hang
their hat on the running game the short
passing game the intermediate passing
game explosive plays it just hasn't
happened for them it's a team right now
that is winning on defense and you know
you never account out Bill Belichick the
guy just knows how to win football games
he's won Super Bowls with I would say
above-average talent and this team
clearly has above-average talent but boy
would you look at some of the dynamic
teams right now particularly the
Baltimore Ravens you say man it's gonna
be hard to get by guys that have that
type of explosive talent because the
pages have shown no ability
come-from-behind do you think that Lamar
Jackson's success is going to open the
door or open eyes with offensive
coordinators and head coaches at looking
at quarterbacks differently in college
oh absolutely and I think the way that
God the college game is now preparing
quarterbacks for the NFL the NFL now
realizes you can take some of these
offensive formations and structures and
philosophies and you can incorporate
them in the National Football League but
then he
is the one issue and this will go back
to you know the days of Randall
Cunningham and Michael Vick and they
even go way back to Bobbie Douglas or
the Bears we had you know those running
style quarterbacks you can't put three
of them on your roster and that's always
kind of the issue you know you could
find one and boy you got a gym but
you're always putting the quarterback in
harm's way when you're running the
football as much as say a large
accidents or a Michael Vick did or
Randall Cunningham did and the old
theory reduction you just keep beating
on people through they don't want to get
up anymore they get hurt and that's kind
of what happened so all of a sudden you
go to your backup quarterback and say
now I've got a Robert Griffin the third
and in Baltimore you know there's a huge
fall off I mean real Robert Griffin is a
solid player but he's not a Lamar
Jackson right now at this point in his
career so now do you have you have to
restructure your offense what do you do
so you may find one of those guys but
it's very hard to get two or three on
your roster and run the same offense
Jones great to catch up with you have
fun this weekend yes it's Dallas Week in
Philly the towns all lathered up it's a
big game you know there's two seven and
seven teams it'll be fun Thank You Jones
that's a Roger ski former Eagles
quarterback for more Dan Patrick show
tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR Live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]